στην τρίτη μουθητία και την ημέρα που είχα λεγή είχα πει δεν θα ξαναβάλου πο
ψηφιορίται που είπαν όλημα γιατί και είπαδι ότι πιστεύω ότι πρέπει να ξέρεις πότε φεύγεις
από μία θέσεη πρέπει να φεύγουμε να ποιες καρέκλες δεν είναι καρέκλες που μας καθορίσωυ
και εδώ έννιωθα ότι ή θελα να υπάρχει και αυτό το μήνυμα ότι έχω ελπίζω
να συμπληρώσο μια όσον το δυνατόν πιο οφέλημηθητία για την ευρωπαρικινένωση και για τον τόπο
μου και μπορεί να αναλάβει κάποιος άλλος δεν είναι αυτό σκοπός να διατηρόμαστε σε σε
μια θέση ση μια καρέκλα ι αυτό είχαδεί την προεδροφόντελαν και την ίδια μέρα πύρα
και τον πρόεδρο της δημοκρατίας τηλέφωνο και τους είπε ότι εβολοκλήρωση τη θητίας μου εγώ
επιστρεφορκή προσπάθησαν κάποιοι και κλίνουμε με αυτό να σας αποτρέψουν σε σαβικά να αλλάξετε την
απόφαση σας και οι συνεργάτες σασι φίλησνπογενίασας διότι δεν το είχα πιει σε κανένα σε
κανέναν όγως στην οικογένεια μου το είχα αφήσεη να νοηθεί καιη ίδια μου είπαν ότι
εσιπανταξέρει στη είντο καλύτερο για σένα το νιώθεις κάνε όπως τη συνιώθεις νομίζω χεξπλάγικαν και
ναι θα θεωρούσαν και έχει ακόμη που το θεωρούν ότι δεν ήταν ίσω μια αναμενόμενι
απόφαση αλλά ως τέλα νιώθω πολύ καλά με τον εαυτό μου νιώθω ότι έχω πάρει
πάρα πολλά ελπίζω να έχω δώσει και αρκετά και ότι έρχομε πίσω στον τόπο μου
και έχω πάρα πολλά να προσφέρα ο πρόδος τη δημοκρατίας τι σα σίμοταν τον μιρατε
τηλεφων έχω μια πολύ καλη σχέσει με τον πρόεδρο της δημοκρατίας περίμενε αυτό